human sorry Donald
and now I give you my real home visitor
my very good friend mr. Tom
I'm okay
it's kind of a kick for me being here
with a superstar like you on a night
like this although you hardly seem
dressed for the occasion that's very
nice who's your tailor well dizzy who's
yours no more commercials come on let's
go to work
okay Mickey go ahead the nominees for
achievement in an animated short subject
are George and rosemary Eunice McCauley
producer Oh huh the man who planted
trees federic back producer your face
Bill Plympton producer and the envelope
please Mickey yeah huh I must have left
it in my other outfit you got any more
of that magic dust left oh I've heard of
air mail but this is ridiculous
the winner is the man who planted trees
Trebek box producer
I thank the Academy and name of
associated Oh Canada and the CBC and I'm
grateful to Jones you know for a strong
message and to Philip Nolan Christopher
Plummer who said it so well my tank to
Lina Gallo the PR Java be a Leo for
Shane Omaha Jobeth devera in our team
thanks to Asifa and Altos we'll make
animation a great I will share this
universal symbol with all the women and
men who plant trees and hope and work so
hard to protect forests wildlife the
health and the beauty of this world
Saburo bouquet beg mercy glimmer citizen
from murcia tooth Sheena crossed ahem
thanks to you all thank you